it was in a remote compound in the high
desert of New Mexico that police found
the children 11 of them ranging in age
from 1 to 15 and in conditions police
say was shocking they apparently lived
in this partially buried trailer no
running water no plumbing no electricity
the only food a few potatoes and a box
of rice police say the children were
dirty and malnourished they were in bad
shape I mean the children were dirty
they didn't have clothes that fit them
properly just seen him walking around
like that it was it was it was hard to
see him during the search police
arrested this man suraj wa hodge who
they'd been tracking for weeks on
suspicion of abducting his own son in
december he wasn't among the children
rescued a second man Lukas Morton was
also arrested on suspicion of harboring
a fugitive three women believed to be
mothers of the children on the compound
were arrested but later released police
had moved in after being passed a
message from someone inside that people
were starving
it has shocked this small community this
people must be really sick to do
something like that to this kids it
scares me because it you know the safety
of my own children who are teenagers you
know you never know what can happen at
any given point america's seen these
stories before of course in january 13
children were found malnourished having
been allegedly held captive by their
parents at a house in california police
say it appears the children had been
living at this compound for a few months
but it's not known how they ended up
here they're now in the care of welfare
services authorities say their health
and safety is the number-one priority
Gregg Milam Sky News Los Angeles